The shorter leg is 20 meters long, the longer leg is 21 meters, and the
hypotenuse is 29 meters. Great work if you found all three. Now, the setup
might have been tough, so if you got stuck there, watch part of the solution,
and then pause it and see if you can continue solving. To start setting up this
problem, we'll let x be the shortest side of our right triangle. We do this
since we know the longer leg of the right triangle is 1 meter more than the
shorter leg. So, we know this longer leg has to be X plus 1. And now here's
where we want to be careful. We know the hypotenuse is 8 meters longer than the
longer leg. So, we'll take the length of the longer leg, X plus 1, and we'll
add on 8 meters. So, the entire length of our hypotenuse Is x plus 1 plus 8, or
just x plus 9. Now we have expressions for each side of our right triangle, and
we can use the Pythagorean Theorem to solve. We square x, which is one of the
legs, and x plus 1, the other leg. This gives us these two expressions and then
we square by hypotenuse x plus 9, to get this expression on the right hand side
of our equation. We combine the light terms here to get 2x squared and the rest
of our equation remains the same. Next we subtract each of these terms from
both sides of the equation. So we have 0 on the right, and x squared minus 16 x
minus 80 on the left. Next, we factor this expression to get x minus 20, times
x plus 4, equals 0. We set each factor equal to 0, which means the solutions
for x could be positive 20 or negative 4, the opposite sign of the factors in
the parentheses. We know a negative side length for x wouldn't make sense in
this case, because we would have negative 4 here. So, this solution is not
valid. When we plug in 20 for x in each of these expressions, we'll get our
side links of 20, 21, and 29. With the hypotenuse being the longest one of 29
units. And since our original side links were reported in meters, we report
each of these in meters.